you may prefer coarser peripherals to
razors but you can't argue that racist
peripherals are not one-of-a-kind and
one of the most aesthetically pleasing
whether you're like razor or not you
have to agree that razors pretty much
mastered the RGB aspect on their
products which is just accentuated by
the perfect synapse software and that
leather wrist rest but their targets
just small niche market with only a
handful of peripherals and some laptops
so how were they able to carve
themselves their own little bubble
thriving coming right up welcome to
hearty lobbies so how exactly did razor
start up and how can you drive so many
sales make sure stick to the end if you
want to find out the key to their
success but starting off originally
razor wasn't even razor it was just a
substrate of karna LLC which is
established in 1998 in an effort to
develop a high-end gaming mouse the
Boomslang corner of least eraser
Boomslang Gaming Mouse in 1999 and it
took the world by storm it became a
standard and it was held in very high
regard by both the gaming industry and
the gaming community but unfortunately
soon after that the dot-com bubble burst
hopes were dashed dreams were shattered
and Carra LLC was closed in 2000 due to
financial issues
it's a racer that we know and love today
was revived in 2005 by min-liang 10 and
Robert Krakov who still believed in a
potential appraiser and were avid gamer
himself after they procure the rights
for a razer brand it took them a couple
of years to actually release something
substantial with their first substantial
lease coming out in CES of 2011 this is
when the review of the brailers
switchblade which was a handheld gaming
device prototype while it did take a
hefty amount of time for them to develop
this it was obviously a fan favorite and
I won the People's Choice Awards in the
CES 2011 however racer wasn't done just
there just two years later he released a
gaming tablet computer on his project
Fiona at CES 2013
just a couple of months after that razor
turned around and released a 14 inch and
17 inch razor blade Pro laptops these
were revolutionary laptop at the 14 inch
variant being named the world's thinnest
gaming laptop razor was clearly off to a
great start and continuous launch
game-changing products over next couple
of years and soon enough they actually
had enough capital to start acquiring
other companies for example in 2015 they
acquired Oya in turn 16 thx and just
last year at mo L 2017 was a huge year
for razer as this was the year they went
public
they offered over a billion shares in
the range of 38 to 51 cents per share
and just after first day of trading
their closing IPO was up 80 percent and
this was actually a second most
successful IPO in Hong Kong in 2017
today Razer has a multitude of
peripherals laptops and phones and their
sales numbers are very impressive as of
Razer was the number one maker of gaming
keyboards and gaming mouses in the world
and Razer continues to impress with
their wide range of successful laptops
and gaming peripherals however through
history alone doesn't really explain
their outstanding success the fact that
there are new player and don't offer a
wide range of PC components makes it
even more surprising for example they
always tell everything from ran to
liquid coolers to SSDs like Coursera is
simply stick to peripherals and laptops
but despite this they easily cost a 100
million dollar mark and revenues every
quarter and this has been continuing for
the last several years so how were they
able to achieve so much success despite
the fact there are targeting such a
niche market and we should late enter
into a gaming scene first let's take a
look at some of the supporting reasons
before we dive into the main thing that
distinguishes them from the rest of the
market Razer targeted a much different
demographic than other companies were
targeting at the time for example
courser was hung up on targeting the
casual gamer while other companies were
tending to average gamers of the budget
however Razer ignored all of this and
targeted an enthusiast gamer with a
flexible budget their slogan is
literally for gamers
by gamers and with that they played
target an enthusiast gamer who is okay
with spending a little bit more money
for a better quality product or just
even flair and this release separated
them from the other companies because
while other companies did have high
level gaming price in their lineup like
Corsair with 1395 it was different
coming from razor without solder sold
it's basically like a high-level Honda
Accord or Toyota Camry
versus an Audi a4 the Honda Accord is
probably just as good if not better than
that OTA for for a cheaper price but
most people would actually prefer the
Audi a4 because the brand name
associated with the car same thing goes
for razor they built up a premium name
for themselves and people wanted a
greater product they were able to build
up a reputation for perfection and
aesthetics and they're really able to
showcase this to their social media
presence and of course a crucial part of
their growth was her social media
presence they didn't necessarily engage
with the community too much or ask the
community for their opinions for the
next car launches like Coursera did
which is what sets them apart however
social media was the perfect place for a
racer to showcase what their parts were
truly capable of and expose it to a lot
more people it's not until you see a
Razer product until you really
understand how clean and sleek their
posture really are and experience the
true potential for RGB and let me just
say Razer hands down no doubt has the
best RTP implementation on the market
there are software and customizations
are first-class and their colors are
really rich and vibrant
there's snaps softer along with their
website are really well designed and
easy to use and this is perfect for
converting a random viewer on the social
media website to a customer overall
social media was a perfect way for
racially get some more exposure and show
the true potential of all of their
products speaking of exposure one of the
other biggest reasons for their growth
was influencer and what I say
influencers I'm not talking about
youtubers I'm actually
about eSport players of course youtubers
a great exposure for a racer but often
times youtubers do not exactly recommend
their products this was because even the
youtubers thought that razor made great
parts they simply just didn't think that
was worth the price and I am really glad
that these youtubers are honest and
Express how they really felt about these
products but this is not good news for a
razor and this led to really low
conversions from youtubers but were they
shine with esports esports players
obviously want to have the best
peripherals to be on the top of their
game eSports players obviously want to
be playing at the top of their game and
for many of these eSports players they
really liked Razer peripherals
especially their Mouse's as a result
when the public saw high-level eSports
players using razor peripherals these
are associated with a premium experience
and high level gaming and while
youtubers didn't necessarily recommend
Razer products they had a lot of great
things to say about them this created a
perception that even though razors
products may be on the pricier side they
are definitely worth it if you wanna
have a premium gaming experience and
this tip many consumers to spend extra
money and buy Razer peripherals but even
that isn't the key reason that Razer was
able to capture so much market share so
what is the key reason well the answer
to that question is posh I see your tan
has set himself Razer is deleting
lifestyle brand for gamers and this
intently shines through in all of their
products first let's take a look at
their keyboards their lowest level
keyboard the Razer cyanosis comes in at
about 50 is $60 and even this keyboard
not only has RGB but is perky
individually backlit which means that
each game could produce sixteen point
eight million different colors and they
even has the illuminated RGB Razer logo
on literally the base level now if you
go one model up you get the razor Ornato
other razor or nada is a great keyboard
great sound great feeling overall just
great keyboard but you can't deny that
it is not mechanical what makes this
even better than their base level Razer
cyanosis
is that a default comes the really nice
wrist rest it feels very soft and it is
magnetic so it is easy to remove if you
don't want it but the price comes
another very steep one hundred dollars
for keyboard that isn't even mechanical
moving on now you know the Black Widow
elite now of course you guys know how
great this keyboard is but again the
price isn't very expensive at one
hundred and seven dollars and finally
you have the top-of-the-line Huntsman
lead at $200 and it has that sick RGB
LED light strip around the whole
keyboard that even goes into your wrist
rest now I don't care who you are but
that's pretty dope hoarser also has
keepers in this range like a k95 but it
simply does not have the flare there
razor has and plus Corsa also offers
much more budget-friendly options while
razor does not razor's Hulk Park mine up
just has a special Flair even on the non
RGB variants and this trend continues
into other peripherals as was just
ananka basileus and mamba gaming mice
and a Kraken and naari headsets their
whole peripheral lineup is on the
pricier side but their outstanding
quality on comparable implementation of
RGB and impeccable designer attention to
detail it does justify the price and it
is this extra brazier of flair that
drives sales for all of their products
now I know that a lot of you guys may
say that radius quality is subpar for
the price of their charging however for
most people the stellar aesthetics an
RGB of implementation more than make up
for the shortcomings Indian for
peripherals razors main driver of sales
is their posh design complemented by the
unique benefits which you can't find
from other companies like their nice
leather wrist rest and this is really
what sets them apart from the
competition now let's move into a
completely different Reem laptops and
you'll probably start to see a trend
with razor here razor is smallest queen
sized laptop is a 13-inch model and the
cheapest 13-inch model the Razer Blade
stealth 13 comes in at a whopping $1,400
they're starting prices literally higher
than Apple Mac books which started
twelve hundred dollars which is already
very high moving up the products
if they're 15-inch laptop with a gtx
card what cost you at least $1,600 and
if you want to equip it with the
architects card instead they'll cost you
at least twenty three fifty dollars and
finally the top line 17 inch laptop
comes in at $1,700 now put a 4k screen
on it and you're about to double the
price to $3,300 did you want some more
storage like a 2 terabyte SSD
well now that's can cost you forty two
hundred dollars now I am NOT saying that
razored laptops are bad or not worth the
money that's up for you to decide all I
am trying to say is that razor Tarkus
the high-end market makes your products
as appealing as possible and it's not
afraid to charge lot for them and this
is ability of premise of your sales
model make a really high quality
products that look very aesthetically
pleasing and sell them to the high-end
market for a hefty price now this is no
new idea and has been done several times
in the past with several huge companies
the best example of this is Apple with
them literally being the biggest company
in the world being valued over 1
trillion dollars going back to their
roots Mac's were always the more
expensive option but they're also the
more elegant and user-friendly option or
compared to Windows PCs on top of this
Mac's lacked customization and still
really do you have to buy an adapter
just to plug in a USB but these
shortcomings definitely don't deter
millions of people from buying them
anyways same thing goes for their phone
lineup but they first launched the
original iPhone 6 hundred and $50 were
downright insane to pay for a phone but
nowadays it is very hard to find someone
who doesn't have an iPhone or a form of
equal caliber and price as it is evident
people really like nice parts and her in
many cases willing to pay more money for
them however this is not always work
which is also shown by Apple with the
release of the iPhone 10s and 10x Mac's
last year so it is definitely a risky
bargain but it clearly worked out and
razors favor and this is precisely what
rates are target's razor was the
original player who offered high-level
enthusiasts great gaming peripherals and
PC components
and for the people who want to just a
little bit more in the average game
perform like some more RGB or a more
aesthetically pleasing design or a nice
wrist rest razor was a clear choice
there's sleek website design and great
social media presence only accelerated
this process other companies start to
pick up on this and start to launch such
products of themselves the best example
of this is basis as our og gaming
keyboards and masses like the claim work
but Razer has already well established
himself in this niche market and it was
hard for Asus to compete in the end
Razer is pretty much the apple of the
game market and that's exactly how they
rose to Fortune so what do you guys
think about Razer prize and what company
would you like make our next make sure
comment that down below also if you guys
enjoyed this via the meter drop a like
and consider subscribing if you would
like to see more videos just like this
one but until then I'm Ari I'll see you
guys on Nashville
[Music]